how's this rep attention bombshell a
report from real clear investigations
claims that Justice Department IG
Michael Horowitz is about to issue his
investigative finding that former FBI
director Jim Comey was quote running a
covert op against the president starting
with a private defensive briefing he
gave Trump just weeks before his
inauguration the piece also notes that
Comey had an agent inside the White
House who reported back to FBI
headquarters about Trump and his aides
according to other officials familiar
with the matter here to react to this
bombshell a lot more chairman of the
House Senate Judiciary Committee Lindsey
Graham senator should Comey face charges
this is if this is true this is Wow well
not based on a newspaper article but if
he did subvert justice if he did lie to
the FISA Court then he's not above the
law did he actually take the law in his
own hands the question is when it came
to Trump did they take the law in their
own hands
well they felt it was their duty it
seemed like I mean he was hiding behind
everything very is a very empirical you
know jumping in the presidential
election twice was his duty right well
right now this is hot with Muller's
testimony on Wednesday the Democrats
think they're gonna get another bite at
the Apple and you say yeah I think the
Apple has done most Americans were
looking to Muller to tell them what
happened not Nadler do you think any
fair-minded American believes that
Nadler is out to get the truth he's
already convicted the president in his
own mind this is all about impeachment
they impeach the president over the
Muller report Trump will get reelected
will take the house in the Senate you
are in the impeachment manage jobs in
there that's right and in Lindsey now 90
Democrats in the House have signed on to
impeachment one Republican Justin Amash
well here's their problem if they don't
Center them for impeachment they may get
a primary there 31 Democrats that whole
seats were President Trump when their
district if they vote against aoc in
that crowd they get a primary if they
vote for impeachment they'll lose their
their job so I really do believe
impeachment would be bad for the country
but get president reelected alright we
got to talk about this situation at the
border just because we don't have a
headline a day doesn't mean
we're on this cover everywhere I go
people say what about this border
situation secure and protect act I know
people say I don't want to here by the
legislation my eyes glaze over this
could solve yes the problem and you're
introducing this legislation very
quickly what would it do so people
understand this and they were to change
our asylum law said Jeff to apply for
asylum in your home country Mexico not
the United States if you bring a small
child to America we're gonna have more
time to process the case so you don't
have to release the family 20 days
decision so if you don't want to
separate families you can't do it in 20
days we're going to increase the time to
adjudicate family claims we're going to
require a solemn outside the country
well the Democrats say they don't want
to work right they don't want to work
with Republicans they have they in their
own minds they have successfully opted
out of working with the Republicans
except on this outrageous budget what
I'm going to ask you about but they said
well Trump's are racist so we're not
gonna work with him he's a racist he
puts kids in cages bla bla bla bla bla
you hear the whole thing Hollywood's has
a drumbeat going track for me and
illegal immigrants this year 52,000
released in the El Paso sector go so we
didn't have room to hold them it's just
a matter of time to a terrorist gets in
this crowd and comes here and hurts us
we're not screening everybody we can't
we can't screen everybody grading
everybody I saw when I was there to the
Border Patrol agents you're doing
they're doing a great job job this
system is broken it's not a crisis it's
a disaster and Lindsay what is going on
with this budget bill I mean I've got to
say I had to hit the President on this
you know three hundred twenty billion
dollars in increased spending only what
77 billion in offsets yeah here's this
problem he's got a Democratic House it's
not gonna offset spending he's got a
military that was broken for eight years
during Obama he's trying to rebuild it
so he said we spend a huge amount in the
military loss
I mean conservatives are about fiscal
conservatism too right I know we don't
have both houses of Congress but well
this is a job nightmare but the number
one job of people in the building behind
me is protect the country during the
Obama years we spent less on defense
than any time since World War two the
planes were breaking what about the next
generations how what are they gonna how
are they gonna pay for this do we care
about that anymore fix entitlements
we're not in debt because we're
defending the nation
because we make promises we can't keep
the Medicare Social Security and
Medicaid that's why we're in debt what
does medicare-for-all do that's this
gonna bankrupt Medicare faster is it not
I mean boy it will destroy health care
will destroy the budget that the green
New Deal destroys the economy in the
name of saving the environment but the
number-one job of this president's
protect the United States from enemies
foreign and domestic he said he would
never agree to another cromnibus he said
he would veto it last year I covered it
on the show and I got to hold everybody
accountable here he said he would veto
it he is signing this legislation and
apparently was always with it was like
Nancy and and Chuck a couple of people
or agreed behind closed doors this was a
new name sign it then the government
shuts down or we do a continuing
resolution in to everybody listening
speaking of damocles towards those who
are fighting this war deserve better now
those who have been sacrificing since
9/11 the 1% deserve a commander-in-chief
who have their back and finally we got
one I wish we had the house and didn't
have to spend so much but it is what it
is I care about defending the country if
you want to fix the budget do
entitlement reform and I hope the
president will win Lindsey I know you
were watching that video we wrap it up a
couple of times of the police getting
doused with big you know buckets of
water and just walking away in Harlem
because they have a mayor deblasio who's
a disaster but the respect for the
police the other side will say well the
police don't respect African Americans
and they have a great but your reaction
to that my reaction is that when
Congress women till the country that
we're running concentration camps at the
border that's a slander against those
protecting us when any of water on cops
trying to do their job it's a disrespect
for the law houses start from the top so
this is why I'm glad Trump is taking on
the four because they're disrespecting
those who are risking their lives go to
this border with me and see if you'd
want to do that job for one day how'd
they do it day in and day out with a
crap they get I don't know but I've had
it
mr. president keep defending those who
are defending this country and to our
friends in New York if you don't take
care of your cops shame on you and good
and the poor people who are going to
call on the cops when they need them and
they're too demoralized to act Senator
Graham thank you so much for being here
tonight